der fotograf rothorn strada gerade im
benachbarten abchasien unterwegs als er
2007 vom zuschlag der winterspiele in
sotschi erfuhr
er konnte es kaum glauben dass die
olympischen winterspiele an der küste
des schwarzen meeres im süden russlands
stattfinden sollen
wir waren im winter quasi und pflückten
mandarin direkt von den bäumen in
unseren t-shirts dachte nur was für ein
seltsamer ort für winterspiele
wir kannten auch die regionen wenig und
sowohl abchasien als auch der
nordkaukasus
beides konfliktregionen willkommen in
sotschi
der erste subtropische ort in dem
winterspiele stattfinden
auch im winter herrschen hier warme
temperaturen rotthaus 3 und sein kollege
arnold von brüchen dokumentierten fünf
jahre lang die region um sotschi vor
allem die nahegelegene konfliktregion im
nordkaukasus
so trafen sie auf einen polizisten der
bei einem bombenanschlag seinen arm und
sein augenlicht verloren oder auf
verschwundene väter ihre töchter
vergeblich suchen
brutaler alltag im vergessenen
hinterland der nicht so recht ins licht
von olympia passen
wieso 50 milliarden dollar in einen ort
punkten wenn 100 kilometer weiter die
dörfer weder elektrizität noch gas haben
das sind die wichtigen fragen eine
antwort auf diese frage fand horster in
sotschi vergangenheit zu sowjetzeiten
galt sie als eine art russischen riviera
am schwarzen meer wo sich die
oberschicht zu erholen pflegte monster
besuchte die alten prachtvollen
sanatorien um dem verblichenen glanz
nachzuspüren einen glanz an denen auch
putin anknüpfen wollte alles gute der
sowjetunion
das ist sotschi und jetzt versucht putin
all dieses gute von damals im modernen
leben wieder herzustellen
er will uns damit sagen eigentlich war
die sowjetunion gar nicht so schlecht 50
milliarden dollar um aus einem in die
jahre gekommenen badeort ein highend
winter ressort zu machen
eine neue verbindungsstraße vom strand
in die berge inklusive
doch horst rapp schaute hinter die
bergketten dort wo die repression
beginnt in der nacht kam ein paar autos
zu ihrem haus und verhafteten diesen
jungen mann sein vater sprang sofort
sein wagen um ihn zu folgen
später suchte er ihn ging zur polizei
doch niemand gab auskunft und am ende
waren sie sicher er wurde entführt und
getötet
horns traktierte immer wieder in die
region zurück und erzählt davon wie die
familien die er trifft durch bomben
anschläge entführungen und morde
auseinandergerissen worden
jeder hat einen toten oder einen
vermissten zu beklagen
offizieller unterstützung der regierung
gibt es keine diese ganzen versprechen
der russischen regierung die situation
im nordkaukasus zu beruhigen
nichts davon geschah dass der druck auf
die aufständigen erhöht wurden das
führte zu noch mehr gewalt mehr
explosionen mehr verhaftungen und noch
mehr verschwundenen jungen männern das
sotschi projekt besticht durch seinen
menschlichen blick auf die abgründe der
olympischen winterspiele
nun erhielten rob horns tra und sein
kollege von brüchen ein einreiseverbot
nach russland